monsieur trudeau bon soit les ir on est
chez vous dans votre circonscription
pour voir dans papineau et vous avez le
temps d'y retourner quelquefois malgré
la crise elle a couvert la coved ça a
été difficile survenu pour un événement
soirée pour remercier les bénévoles il
ya quelques semaines j'en viens à
montréal
assez régulièrement pour passer au
bureau mais c'est étoffe le tavel
acolytes pour être présent avec l'état
mettant et c'est offre donc vous dites
pour bien des gens dr thanh disait
aujourd'hui la tempête va finir par chez
nous on a l'impression qu'on voit pas le
bout est-ce que comment vous en êtes
tous là aujourd'hui dans votre analyse
ce qui va arriver dans le prochain mois
les deux prochains mois mais c'est sûr
que les canadiens au fait des bonnes
choses des choses extraordinaires des
deux parmi les plus vacciner au monde
d'avoir suivi les consignes aux nues une
pandémie moins pire que bien d'autres
endroits mais ça veut pas dire qu'on
peut relâcher malheureusement avec au
micro il va falloir que une fois de plus
on fasse des sacrifices et je sais que
les gens sont tannés
mais ce qui est encore le staline nous
travailleurs de la santé un buzz qui
oeuvrent si nous on a moins eu des des
vagues pour eux ça a été pas mal
constant sont épuisés sont et si on
arrive avec une grosse vague souhaite à
noël comme on pourrait avoir avec au
micro on va voir nos systèmes de santé
déborde et c'est pour ça que les gens
doivent encore une fois faire ce qu'on
sait comment faire maintenant garder nos
distances rétrécir la bulle se faire des
doses de rappel faire vacciner nos
enfants on sait quoi faire
malheureusement il va d'abord qu'on le
fasse beaucoup de gens ils cessent de
quelques jours sur la troisième dose la
fameuse dose de rappel ce legault québec
a dit imam de vaccinateurs est ce que
vous envisagez des mesures comme demande
aux militaires d'ouvrir aller au stade
olympique de la tron pour de lier pour
faire des grands centres de vaccination
si c'est nécessaire on est là pour
donner cet appui aux provinces d'abord
on ne put obtenir assez de dose de
rappel pour tous les canadiens on les a
donc c'est juste ça s'apprend les
effectifs pour les ménages et ça prend
les gens pour venir se faire offrir un
brin ça vaut ce faire on est là pour
aider si nécessaire mais encore une fois
on a vu qu'on est capable de faire
énormément raté non quand on travaille
tous ensemble il ya
76 % des canadiens vaccinés de dons
comment dans votre esprit on convainc
les autres où on est convaincus parce
que c'est sarah on
continue d'essayer d'encourager les gens
ne voient on voit que les ce qu'elle les
conséquences d'avoir la corruption n'est
pas vacciné sont bien plus graves
scissions qui va faire déborder à noël
où nous nous nos soins d'urgence donc on
va continuer de dire c'est la bonne
chose on a des millions des milliards de
personnes à travers le monde qui se sont
fait vacciner aussi que c'est la bonne
chose à fin et c'est comme ça qu'on va
passer à travers les frontières est ce
que vous avez envisagé cette semaine de
refermer avec les américains on ne
réfléchit à tout parent si la fermeture
était une hypothèse c'est toujours in
his hypothèse mais et parce qu'on a pu
fermer les frontières pendant longtemps
tout en permettant
les biens essentiels et le commerce qui
était si essentiel pendant ces deux
dernières années mais je pense qu'on est
pas rendu là et d'ailleurs avec ou
micron présent déjà partout de fermer
carrément et frontières j'étais pas
nécessairement la même utilisation de
nos ressources
il ya d'autres choses à faire comme
d'interdire la et de lutter contre la
transmission communautaire à d'être là
pour le dépistage d'être là pour nos
carrières de santé pour près des halles
donc les français
les spécialistes vous dise il est trop
tard de toute taille on a levé les
restrictions pour les pays d'afrique
aujourd'hui ça va être en vigueur dans
la quelques jours au micro et des jeux
ici ça sert à rien de le faire on a pris
des mesures il ya deux trois semaines
qui ont ralenti l'arrivée de micron
pouvait pas l'empêcher c'est ce parce
que les canadiens quels que soient nos
barrières la frontière vont toujours
pouvoir retourner au canada donc il va
toujours avoir une certaine transmission
c'est juste de minimiser d'acheter du
temps c'est ce qu'on a fait est donc
maintenant on peut dire on va se
concentrer oui pour faire du dépistage
des gens qui reviennent le voyage on va
encourager les gens de ne pas choisir de
voyager pour des raisons données
essentielle mais vous regarde
je vous ai quand même posé la question
parlant de on va chacun faire ne
paraisse que vous avez réduit vous vos
fêtes de noël personnellement oui tout à
fait tout à fait on avait parlé de
rassembler quelques amis pour vous mais
50e pour devoir
oui mais on voit si les bristols et et
s'arrête toujours le fun pour moi
d'abord d une fête d'anniversaire l'été
là si ça vaut mieux bon monsieur leubou
hier en parlait on a dû refaire en fait
des restaurants leur demande un autre
effort est ce que ça va être le retour
de la pcu ou de dos des programmes comme
ça un sport mais on est prêt à le faire
si nécessaire parce que on sait que la
mère chose pour l'économie
c'est de bien contrôler la coved 19
c'est ce qu'on a fait dès le début parce
que oui on a mieux contrôlé que vivent
beaucoup d'autres pays et on a vu notre
économie revenir en force on a des
mesures qu'on a passées à la chambre
récemment qui vont permettre de l'aide
pour ceux qui en ont besoin mais on
espère en avoir moins besoin mais comme
j'ai dit depuis le début on va être là
pour les si c'est nécessaire
l'inflation c'est un sujet de
préoccupation pour les canadiennes ce
trou d'eau
il ya cette impression parce qu'il n'y a
pas de retour au déficit zéro là vous
dans les prochaines années vous n'avez
pas donné un plan pour le retour à zéro
il ya des gens dans une salle des
finances conduire n'est plus là dedans
mais quand même on al'impression vous
dépenser sans lunettes
s'est passé vous salue absolument pas on
a fait les investissements nécessaires
pour pouvoir aider les gens à ne pas
voir un un désastre économique qui
aurait été bien pire que ce qu'on a vécu
on était là avec de l'aide historique
pour les familles mais de l'or pur dit
sur disney direct du fédéral parce que
on savait que c'était mieux que le
gouvernement s'endette un petit peu plus
pour éviter que les ménages sans lionel
nallet oui si un jour on
va s'en sortir est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
désir d'en balancer les livres
absolument absolument et on ne montrait
pas dans vos prévisions montre
effectivement que la taille de notre
dette comme proportion de notre économie
va continuer à diminuer même avec tous
les investissements qu'on est en train
de faire et c sont la responsabilité
fiscale qui est nécessaire est
d'ailleurs que les les experts à
l'international 10 le canada est en
santé de façon fiscale économie ok mais
on n'est plus dans le déficit zéro non
on est dans les investissements
nécessaires pour faire croître notre
économie
malgré les grands défis auxquels on fait
donc vous êtes on peut s'accommoder
d'une d'un défi set mais est ce que ce
que les gens
ce qui rassure les gens c'est que le
coup de payer les intérêts sur nos
dettes en tant que pays sont plus basses
maintenant qu'ils étaient avant la
pandémie à cause des deux bateaux
d'intérêts à cause des des choses qu'on
a aimé ça que je m'ennuie très mauvais
on a on a on a signé des accords pour
pouvoir justement garder ses taux ses
taux bas pendant plusieurs années pour
notre dette se trouve au château québec
la loi 21 le débat a été relancé avec
cet enseignant de chelsea pendant la
campagne vous avez toujours été comme
vous l'avez jamais caché mais disons que
le ton était plus plus doux là on a
senti le lion plus sortir en a c'est
inacceptable est-ce que vous empêcher de
débattre à cause de l'élection comment
vous situez aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui
c'est plus seulement une des beautés or
etc sur la défense des droits des
minorités on a vu un exemple concret
d'une jeune femme qui n'est plus
enseignante aujourd'hui parce qu'elle
est musulman et ça c'est une c'est un
constat que beaucoup de québécois à
chelsea et ailleurs dans la province
sont en train de dire mais nous on est
une province libre province ouverte un
endroit où on défend la liberté
d'expression et l'égalité des gens la
liberté de conscience il semble qu'il ya
quelque chose qui cloche si une jeune
femme peut perdre sa job à cause sa
religion et justement je veux dire oui
oui ça devrait clocher parce que - aucun
québécois est surpris du fait que je
défend les droits des minorités vous
êtes toujours le faire je pense que
c'est important dans une société
pluraliste et ouverte et je le ferai
toujours mais jusqu'où peut aller le
faire est ce qu'il y aura un moment où
j'allais sauter sur la glace le fédéral
vous allez être actif dans ce combat
d'abord les québécois des québécois sont
déjà extrêmement active dans ce courant
qu'on est de combat a contesté cette loi
devant pour parce que c'est une loi
provinciale qui sont en train de
contester nous entende fédéral je
l'étais aujourd'hui on ne ferme pas la
porte intervenir à un jour peut-être à
la cour suprême c'est ce que je dis
depuis des années et la phase également
semble plus ouverte qu'elle ne l'était
elle a toujours été ouverte une porte
est ouverte ou fermée gelé toujours les
civils est d'accord mais parce que dans
vous le voyez au canada anglais est ce
que vous approuvez tout ce qui est en
train de se passer les maires des
grandes villes canadiennes bob rae votre
ambassadeur à l'onu qui dit ça va à
l'encontre des droits de la personne
est-ce que vous approuvez touchard ne
savons pas trop loin je pense que la
réalité à comprendre est ce que je
partage tout le temps avec tous les gens
en dehors du québec
ce que les québécois c'est des gens qui
défendent la liberté d'expression on est
une société qui défend la liberté de
confiance lui a conscience la légalité
en fait on en croit as libéré on croit
défendre ses droits fondamentaux et donc
je peux très bien démontré qu'il ya
beaucoup de québécois qui se posent des
questions sur ce procès cette loi là
mais de dire que votre ambassadeur à
l'onu 10 devant la communauté
internationale que c'est une loi qui va
à l'encontre des droits de la personne
est ce que ça ne va pas trop loin
j'ai toujours dit que j'ai énormément de
préoccupation moi même avec ce projet
doit alors attendons avec cette loi
pourquoi est ce que est ce que je dirai
à nos diplomates et d'ailleurs si on
revient à l'air un peu on encourage nos
diplômes a justement à exprimer leurs
perspectives et leur valeur et c'est
dans les valeurs des canadiens y compris
des québécois de défendre les droits des
minorités mais ce que ce débat là ne
peut pas se faire en baissant le ton en
accusant port les québécois la nation
que vous reconnaissez maintenant d'être
raciste mais au contraire si vous
m'écoutez chez tout le temps en train de
dire ça les québécois on est toujours là
pour défendre une société libre liberté
d'expression liberté de conscience et
c'est pour ça justement que beaucoup de
québécois sont en train de se poser des
questions sur cette loi qui briment qui
limite ses libertés d'expression et de
conscience monsieur trudeau monsieur
legault en pleine campagne électorale
dit voté pour à peu près tout le monde
sur vous et le npd du parti
centralisateur est-ce que ça a produit
des effets sur votre relation actuelle
comment vous portez non moins bluffante
au personnel et d'ailleurs quand les
québécois
a ajouté que j'étais surpris un petit
peu mais je connais les québécois je
suis fier d'être québécois et je sais
qu'il québécois ont choisi dans cette
campagne électorale de voter pour un
gouvernement qui étaient là pour
défendre des causes l'environnement à
pau lutter contre les changements
climatiques pour défendre les droits des
femmes pour lutter contre les armes à
feu l'est pour le contrôle des armes à
feu à tous les politiques qu'on mettait
de l'avant qui que les conservateurs ne
voulait pas que compterait les québécois
ont voté pour pour des 10 des
progressistes alors je suis très content
de comment ça finit ce qui est dans
votre relation avec le premier du québec
n'en a pas souffert du tout je toujours
être là pour travailler main dans la
main avec n'importe quel autre ministres
des provinces y compris le premier
ministre le go pour livrer pour les
citoyens en 22 à ce que la question de
l'argent des transferts en santé va être
réglé d'une façon ou d'une autre ça
avance ça avance et se mais comme je dis
toujours on va parler du long terme une
fois on en a fini avec la pandémie est
là avec au micro on est de retour et
dans notre énoncé économique on investit
des milliards de plus pour aider les
provinces ajustements g cette pandémie
on est encore là dedans et on va être là
pour des millions des milliards de
dollars pour appuyer le système de santé
dans cette crise si on veut être là pour
le long terme aussi mais c'est une
conversation qu'on aura en temps et lieu
sur toulouse va finir avec des petites
rafales donc réponses courtes question
plus court chemin rock sam mais ce qu'on
laisse entrer et des dizaines de
personnes chaque jour jour et nuit est
ce qu'on les laisse entrer éternellement
parce que il ils ont encore en mémoire
votre tweet en disant venez au canada on
vous accueille et vous tu es c'est
plutôt à cause de donald rheault et de
ce qui se passe aux etats unis une jauge
entier il lui est el mechri et il le
canada va continuer d'être un pays
ouvert à l'immigration mais la raison
pour laquelle on est ouverts les
migrations sait qu'on a un système qui
suit les règles et donc on est en train
de travailler avec les etats-unis pour
régler cette question là des traversée
irrégulière pendant ce que en
travaillant sur sur le l'accord sur les
tiers partis donc on devrait le revoir
en 22 on est en train d'en discuter avec
les états unis justement ce fait ces
lots ça fait longtemps qu'on en discute
mais on espère à bout c'est pas ça ne
peut pas et éternel l'entrée donc ça
devrait pas parce qu'elle a confiance
que les gens ont dans notre système
d'immigration et d'être notre bienvenue
à des immigrants c'est parce qu'ils ont
confiance que notre système rigoureux ok
watchou et elle menace qu on est à
l'abri du nom qui ne savent pas si
longtemps sur deux ans oui tu souhaitais
c'était un un
désaccord entre des chefs élus de cette
bande là qui étaient en faveur d'un
projet d'oléoduc de gaz naturel et des
chefs irid iter qui n'étaient pas en
accord et sociaux non jeu qu'une
différentes qu'ils ont à régler entre
eux nous en tant que pays on est là pour
les aider pour essayer d'encourager un
ce règlement mais aussi pour faire des
progrès sur le chemin de la
réconciliation d'investir dans les
communautés dans les opportunités
économiques
est ce qu'on a fait des progrès de louis
xii oui on a fait des progrès
j'en ai même dans nos la question des
statuts nous arrête ou après réflexion
on les enlève on le garde je pense que
c'est important d'avoir ces discussions
là il ya des endroits où on devrait
sûrement les garder on regarde ce qu on
la remet ça c'est une question pour la
ville de montréal si on imagine un musée
qui a des photos très mimi nest on
enlèverait pour l'une des photos une
statue dans un square public peut-être
que c'est un autre une conversation mais
c'est des gens qui doivent avoir cette
conversation de façon raisonnable et en
s'écoutant les uns les autres est ce que
le fédéral pour investir avec votre ami
branche même dans le stade de baseball
morges pas intéressés à investir de
l'argent public dans des sports
professionnels il y aura toujours des
façons d'encourager des investissements
qui aident à une communauté mais dans
les sports professionnels
on reste à l'écart en terme de
gouvernement fédéral monsieur trudeau
les changements climatiques est ce qu'on
a besoin d'une évolution sans qu'un
évolution vous faites évoluer mais on
n'a pas plutôt besoin d'une révolution
et que ça fasse mal citoyens d'ici trois
à peut-être votre départ qui s'est
d'abord ce que ce qui est ce qu'on a
réussi à faire comme grand mouvement
c'était justement d'amener une
tarification du carbone dans les
endroits qu'ils ne voulaient pas la voir
à travers le pays en s'assurant que ça
passe pommes aux citoyens effectivement
on parle de plus d'urgence on va amener
plus de mesure mais on peut le faire en
s'assurant que ça fasse pas mal aux
jambes mais il faut être selon lui c'est
pas un leurre de penser ça me fera pas
mal aux citoyens et non parce que si par
exemple on aide à encourager l'achat
d'un véhicule électrique qu'on donne de
l'argent pour pour que ce soit aussi
abordable à cherry que l'électrique
qu'une voiture à combustion ça fait pas
mal et ça nous pose dans la bonne
direction mais se traduire ce que c'est
votre dernier mandat voté ce prix le
mérite non et parce qu'on vous pose la
question d'y toucher une qualification
extrêmement légitimer son pouvoir après
les deux ans connu ça a été du gros
travail mais moins cher entre en
politique pour servir les gens tapis
nous pour servir les canadiens avec tout
ce que j'avais et dans un moment de
crise on a pu faire de grandes choses et
on a pu apprendre comment faire de
grandes choses que je veux maintenant à
mener pour lutter contre les changements
climatiques encore plus en crise du
logement réconciliation des grandes
choses à faire et gérant de l'epr ce
trou d'eau merci on se souhaite qu'au
micro ça pèse un peu on a un début
d'année plus libre merci de nous avoir
parlé joyeuses fêtes merci patrice ça
fait toujours plaisir à voir